foreign
which is doing everything which is
related to it nowadays it's definitely
way more than just IIT it's business
transformation and Technology
transformation and of course cyber
security we are using today the
chronicle soar solution which is one of
the most important tools within our
cyber defense platform as a service
provider we have to make sure that every
single customer gets the same service
the same customer experience and
therefore the platform is very important
and with Chronicles or this is one of
the element which helps us to to to
deliver that
your value with Chronicles or as part of
the Cyber defense platform is that we
are faster we see a lot of scalability
having better kpis having better
reporting having better visibilities so
they can work on more incidents in the
same period of time they scale better so
we can add more customers with the same
team so there is definitively a big
benefit or big value for the Cyber
defense team
I'm happy to partner with Google cloud
in regards to our cyber defense services
that makes me happy because we are safe
with that within our cyber defense
platform since we started that platform
with Chronicles or we had the chance to
raise customers by more than 100 percent
and of course not adding resources on
that so there is a big benefit with that
partnership thanks to the chronicle
Source solution from Google Cloud that
we can scale way better than before of
course we're always focusing on the
customer but at the end we should focus
again also on our cyber defense team if
they would love to work with the tool
and the tools then that's cool